let's talk about city on a hill you got
a giant mustache for this project I know
that you guys are probably held up right
now on production but does the mustache
it clearly comes off when you're not
working well yeah it's what it looked
like it was gonna be a while before we
were going to be back at work and you
know I did this weird thing where I
shaved it and then started to let it
grow back right and it makes no sense at
all but if you remember you know back in
the old days there was the same where if
you light a cigarette then the bus comes
because it means that you're never going
to get to fish so that was my mentality
my dream is that we go back into
production and our crew has their jobs
back and and and we've you know tried
we've we've come out of the other side
of this thing before my mustache is
ready that's my dream that's a good it
was a weird sort of like roll of the
dice I'm gonna I'm gonna take it off and
plus my wife you know listen maneuvers
she she is very very supportive of
whatever thing I have to be doing with
my hair or my face or whatever but I you
know it's kind of tough for her to live
with a porn stache for like six months
look it starts off as very erotic and
then the mystery fades let's face it